Carrie Fisher was a whole lot more than
just Princess Leia she was a fierce
advocate for social causes an important
voice for destigmatizing mental illness
a bang-up script doctor on many of your
favorite 1990s movies and an incredible
author it's not often that one person
can be so talented in so many fields but
Fisher was the exception she lived more
in her six decades than most of us ever
will in a lifetime and we'll never know
what more she had in store for us but as
incredible as she was in all these
different ways she's still best known
for one thing above all her role as Leia
in Star Wars her tragic passing due to a
heart attack will almost certainly
affect the future of Star Wars as sad as
we fans are it's impossible not to ask
the question that's on all our minds
what effect might our loss of Carrie
Fisher have on episode 8 and episode 9
will they change episode 8 shooting on
director Rian Johnson Star Wars Episode
8 actually wrapped back in July 2016 and
has been confirmed that Fisher had
already finished her scenes for the 2017
debuting film
so however Disney decides to address
Fisher's passing they have a decent bit
of footage and a good chunk of time to
figure it out
productions this big usually have a
tight schedule but as rogue one showed
us it's not uncommon to go back for
extensive reshoots and editing in the
months leading up to release if Disney
decides to address Fisher's passing in a
more direct way like having general Leia
be written off into retirement or die
heroically there's some time to tackle
that but it might not be easy going full
CGI as the computer-generated cameos in
rogue one made clear fully CGI
characters can't yet seamlessly share
the scream of live actors though the
resurrection of Pizza cushing's grand
moff tarkin was a powerful test for how
far digital effects have come the
resurrected actors still looked a bit
off when acting alongside living actors
on screen
Lucasfilm knew that Tarkin had to be in
rogue one since he's a commander of the
Death Star and they'll be strange for
him to not be there in some capacity
even his limited screen time was a whole
lot of expensive work so it's not really
feasible to try and do this for a main
character in a film if they try to alter
or add Leia scenes digitally it could
get tricky it's been done before if
we're looking for a modern example for
how Fisher's passing might be addressed
on screen
we don't need look further than Furious
7 the
Paul Walker's character story the studio
used a mix of CGI and human stand-ins to
narrative Lear attire Walker's character
and have him ride off into the sunset
with his family it's a viable concept to
apply to Episode eight because Leia is
obviously one of the most iconic Star
Wars characters in the franchise we'll
have to address her absence at some
point in the next couple of films who
leads the resistance next Leia had
become a revered resistance leader by
the beginning of the force awakens so in
the wake of Fisher's passing who will
lead the resistance Star Wars now has a
fair share of strong young heroes and
it's not crazy to think that folks like
Poe Dameron Finn or Ray could eventually
step into that void of course Luke
Skywalker is another obvious option
considering he'll be returning for a
major role in Episode eight so if
they're looking for a steady hand to
take the lead he'd certainly be a worthy
successor how could this affect Luke and
kylo ren's arcs any changes to producers
make to lay a story for the next two
films will resonate with her relatives
Luke and Leia's sibling bond was
definitely important to the script pages
hidden deep inside Lucasfilm and the big
story for Leia and Han in the force
awakens was the effort to turn their son
back from the dark side which didn't end
so well did Lucasfilm plan to rely on
the mother-son story between layer and
kylo Ren and if so how does that story
have to change now could layers absence
change karlo Ren's fate before the new
trilogy comes to an end could
potentially losing both parents push him
to the lights or further into the dark
either way star wars just won't be the
same without Carrie Fisher
[Music]
for you I know thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to my youtube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love to
[Music]